anna on aura un invité mystère on duplex
beaucoup dit un invité mystère et on a
ce soir je vous le dis
exceptionnellement bill du bigdil à tous
on n'arrive toujours pas à faire un
duplex à lui une leçon ça promet l'année
prochaine quand on va changer de studio
ne sont pas du tout oui c'est vraiment
très bien
aujourd'hui c'était souvent un petit peu
spéciale puisque c'est l'anniversaire de
queyries mai 2010 mais j'ai jamais vu un
public aussi mal sont tes attentes et où
nous on dirait qu'on leur avenir chanson
mon frère dj moule
boulard
[Applaudissements]
chez vous vous avez dû remarquer il n'y
a pas un gars qui a chanté dans le bon
sens greg c'est une chanson qu'on sente
jamais on la connaît ya toujours un mais
dans les anniversaires des gens là mais
quand on a une famille août avec des
copains gars qui chante premier degré
happy birthday bah ouais quoi le bras
droit qui fait les auditions de ce vol
et moi comme les mecs qu'ils y vont ils
un peu dans le métier peut-être connais
des gens a sauvé ce combat soit ça
m'arrive comme ça il faut des gens il ya
quand même en garde à vue
[Musique]
ça peut fermer ta gueule
douvres